hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to well
after insulting our rights to be human
beings with kickassia the nostalgia
cricket moved on to even longer projects
that's not what I meant he did
suburbanite nothing like angle maj to a
genre I like doing everything you can to
destroy it
suburban nights tries everything in its
power to make sure that not only does it
take a hit at every single fantasy
building can think of but also to make
sure you never want to see any of those
films again because of it so let's take
a look at what's bigger Longer & uncut
again not what I was talking about this
is suburban nights so have you ever
wondered what Bill and Ted's mutilated
love child looks like we opened up with
him driving a car picking up a
hitchhiker hey buddy
kneel lift yes I'm looking for a ride to
the Dresden Files what do you think of
the 21st century bill dude what are you
on cuz I totally want so well um okay
somebody's movie forgot to take its
depression medication I mean I thought
this was like fun adventure people and
dress up fantasy whoo all sorts of
whimsical comedy did I put in the wrong
movie I mean the back of the film says
it's a hilarious adventure with non-stop
fun
maybe if you call it an arsonist
Christmas yep nothing to follow up that
heavy load it's serious than a jubilant
Porto Rican and red and white shoes
doesn't every heavy dramatic moment
follow with them but it turns out the
car is just a scam provided by the NC
who tricks his producers and coming on
an adventure with it already the credits
are terrible
don't ref you telling someone on the
internet not to review something it's
like telling an idiot not to watch TMZ
so they find out that a role-playing
geek named Jeffers rid of rare expensive
gauntlet thinking that it had some sort
of magical powers and the NC wants his
team to go find it
but wait we need some sort of forced way
to get them into silly costumes
apparently he'd read this as a
role-playing game in order to find
everybody has to get dressed up and act
like a fantasy character in order to
figure out what these riddles meet
around and I bet the quiet game while
babysitting has no other motives either
so the next day the team shows up in a
routine that feels like it lasts a
suburbanite and they show off their
characters in costumes calm acelin no no
no kima this it's been down to
robitussin he's a panda the turret
skelion who'll never grow up
rice decision to making mouse club that
everybody needs an intro to themselves
unless you're this guy in which case you
make it the most pansy intro that you
can fathom so after a few minutes that
feels like a few ice ages we finally get
the journey started well sort you see
the downside here is that mighty planet
wants to come along too but nobody wants
him because well he's mati come get them
planet it's time to chick fakes losing a
contact lens to distract him and thus
only 40 minutes in they finally get the
story going they split into two teams
and start searching for the treasure but
the path is paved with many obstacles Oh
puny mortals I am the defender of this
path ok this is a taste of some of the
obstacles we're gonna get in this movie
I see the obstacles from double-dare are
more intimidating but mr flibble it
turns out is more threatening than led
to
and it seems no one can fight them off
this looks like a job for an Indian
music video yay chanting no not today so
the confusion seems to work and the team
continues I mean while the other team
seems to be moving right along as well
but two team members don't seem to be
having the highest hopes listen great
white north I know you think you're hot
shit around here but let's make one
thing clear
mr. critic is mine you understand I'm
his personal ball washer and don't you
forget it
well I'm so insignificant that why are
you bringing this up your pee just call
me a pee and now it's time to play how
far will you go for a forced joke this
is you you're screaming to the other
page I'm saying yo see it's gonna weed
me but I would eat you please well
and I'm just full right
I am totally full a penis you got so
what are you gonna do I will eat your
penis Wow I can't wait to see what
that's gonna be because I'm gonna edit
it in later but but needless to say
that's a long time but they come across
the Naz goofs who tell them that they
cannot pass any further to make things
worse it seems that they actually do
have magical powers which leads to the
typical Channel awesome battle cry why
are your cells are oh yeah back with
team 1 we see them taking a break as
obnoxiously mugging for the camera every
second there on takes a lot of energy
out of them this leads to this scene
well there's a certain article of
clothing that you have on that you may
not be used to and as such there's a
certain etiquette you might want to keep
in mind while you're wearing it are you
talking about
Jesus I feel like my senses just got one
of those combo hits from the skip con
fighting games are you talking about
wins bola leti mati eventually finds the
missing contact for the e seeing how
nostalgic chick never actually dropped a
contact which means the NC has to think
of another way to get rid of it there's
another special mission that we need you
for
let's see because there isn't enough
material for male porn fanfiction in
this movie mickey lights goats goats
this is a problem that he has to live
with every day look at the anger on that
face look how tormented he is that is
years and years of pain building up you
know it's amazing how much abuse a
certain someone can take and how much
humiliation of film can put that certain
someone through and die just like you
see it and acknowledge it
leave the goats alone nostalgia cricket
there is nothing wrong with animals
wanting to express themselves sexually
if there was we'd see this everywhere
but the trick works and the team goes
along their merry way the other team on
the other hand is not doing so well
more penis jokes please seriously the
humor in this movie is on par with the
birthday card you get at Spencer's last
a were they placed a call-out
battlefield well it only figures this is
where adult children would end up why is
it I get the feeling this is why parents
tell their kids to stay away from
certain people at playgrounds use me but
the powers that be and their kids put
the fight to a halt we must make haste
to another battlefield one more parents
permission matters not and our team
manages to escape leaving the mat behind
our walking Broadway musical doesn't
have much better luck when they come
across a foe even more horrifying than a
puppet cat I don't try to imagine oh
it's Sarah Palin dressed up as a Chuck
Jones wait once again the obstacle seems
to be more dangerous than expected
my god she manages to hit everything
except when she's actually trying to hit
handsome Tom manages to masers the rest
of the crew wonders just how powerful
their enemy's honor meanwhile occur
Winston dumps look-alike comes across
the map but Gandalf the black has other
plans well if it's not yours and taking
it Finders Keepers well at least you
didn't have to star in spider-man 3 in a
strange turn for the moment he seems to
return the map and then suddenly
vanishes away giving these guys just
enough time to vanish it and a mod they
didn't use that before
my name is inigo montoya motherfucker
kind of odd he didn't use that before
King Kong ain't got nothing on me for
the six of you that remember training
day you're laughing your asses off now
but if there's anything history has
taught us is that Americans know how to
screw the Brits those film brain gets
captured and has turned into one of the
cloaks while that's going on the other
teammates come across the location of
the man who started it all Chuck
Shaffers who was banished into a book
and cursed to forever carry a bad Rick
Moranis impression oh yeah he found out
what I was doing it wasn't too happy
that dude is messed up he tells them
that the man following them is malachite
and that he's using them to find his
magic gauntlet so he can have his full
power back but in a pretty eyes nowhere
turned Jeffers decides he hates the
critics and decides to be their enemy
hey man thanks for having to stay here
for 30 years I was trapped in a book a
line which will live in infamy
so the cloaks decide their gang already
looks enough like a Monty Python sketch
without the brittish's help
thus they decide to ditch him and drive
away
bad cuz we've all giggle oh joy no
that's a chileger question why were they
walk-in all time the team gets him back
and eventually hypnotizes him to his
normal self door as normal as Phil
Branca beer
this leads them to the final location
where they find a light that I think is
voiced by the irate gamer who tells them
the backstory of our villain malachite
The Alchemist was named a on the
sorcerer was named malachite the king
told Aeon he wanted to devote all his
power into creating the strongest force
on earth
so a unresponded in reason and science
is where our future lies you know for a
story told on sandpaper it's really not
that bad you will believe an epic tale
can be told by a prison with a Jersey
accent so malachite stopped using magic
allowing him to live longer and longer
watching the world of magic fade and the
world of science and technology consumed
the earth and of course it's always
refreshing having heard such a heavy
story to return to a bunch of ass hats
in Halloween costumes tone you are set
this leads them to the final location of
the gauntlet which it turns out is right
back where they started it's right back
where we started
no you can't get your hour and a half
back by the way that doing the suede
comes back also
I guess he escaped into Ceylon for the
mines of Moria and he shows them the
location of the gauntlet which now turns
out to be a power glove I'm not gonna
lie that is friggin awesome
nice that's like Indiana Jones looking
for the Ark of the Covenant it turns out
it's a turbo graphics 16 unfortunately
they're attacked by the clearance sale
at Hot Topic and they use their magic
and such to try and stop them but
fortunately the rest of the team comes
in to save the day
Roza
sharp winds duality
seems like the day is won but the evil
Michael Jackson backup dancer wants what
is rightfully his and pretty much gifts
yet the team seems to suffer through the
Ninja Turtles movie syndrome as none of
them figure out would actually make more
sense to attack him all at once instead
of one at a time
Oh curses if only we had an obnoxious
plot resolution taken from a cameo
that's been exploited to ridiculous
degrees that's right
mati has the ring to defeat malachite
how did he get the ring why was it
passed out to him when did he ever get
it to begin with never answered I'm just
assuming his family's a bunch of
thieving gypsies
thus malachite is defeated but at what
cost
oh just a small Indian boy that's not
too bad Oh
and just in case you had any question
about liking these characters before
they burn up his body and shove them
into an oatmeal can kindness and decency
thine aims our suburban Knights they
want them into the sky and it seems the
NC has to deal with death plus you were
out looking for the Necronomicon or
something ha oh my god I win a car to be
excitingly continued in a brief side
video on the DVD extras um adventure
this film is stupid the writing is
stupid the characters are stupid the
only words that seem to be leaving my
lips are stupid so I'll just say it
again
stop it stop it stop it but is this the
last that the nostalgia Cricut has to
offer us well what other genre can be
destroyed that they haven't touched yet
no no that's destroyed
you